si estamos ahora mismo nos acompaña john
y en aquel momento era policía de la del
cuerpo de policía de aquí de nueva york
a hoy es ya sargento retirado ese día
vivió los acontecimientos en una
estación de metro y de repente le llegó
una llamada una alerta de que algo
estaba ocurriendo aquí en la 'zona cero'
johnny así como la producción nueva york
es muy ocupada en ese momento todos
recordamos lo que estábamos haciendo en
ese momento estaba ayudando a los
paramédicos en una ambulancia que había
una señora que había joven desmayado en
tren ese era mi área de trabajo y de
repente escucho la radio la central que
dice un avión se acaba de estrellar en
la torre las primeras que fuera el vuelo
11 norte entonces
escuché pero inmediatamente no pensé que
era fundada y odio bueno me quedé atento
a radio
porque pensé que como suele pasar era
una llamada infundada
nosotros esperamos que se confirmen por
las personas en la escena y
efectivamente minutos más tarde
escuchamos que si era confirmada por las
personas que estaba en la escena y aún
así pensé bueno quizás fue una falla
técnica algún accidente y seguía atento
a radio pero ya saben esa ya sabemos que
más tarde
básicamente a las 8 46 vez que se
confirmó ese estrellato y entonces luego
más tarde a las 9 y 3
ya decía que se había colapsado la torre
entonces ahí en ese momento sí ya
sabíamos todo que se trataba de un acto
terrorista quien le indican desde la
central en ese momento qué es lo que
tiene que hacer usted bueno entonces
cuando se colapsó la torre pues la
central nos dice a todos los que
trabajamos en el tren en toda la semana
santa al norte de la 96 que no
movilizaron que regresaremos
inmediatamente a los comandos muchos no
tenían los vehículos porque estábamos en
la estación de tren precisamente pero
despacharon algunas autobuses y mi
guaguas que nos recogieron a todos para
responder para hacer entonces
movilizados
lo que no necesitaron entonces esa
movilización yo ni usted supongo que
tiene que cerrar las estaciones de metro
efectivamente eso lo que se indicaba
ahora debo decir algo que recuerdo los
rostros cuando finalmente llegamos a la
estación de comando 145 y san nicolás
nunca se me olvidará los rostros de
todos los oficiales que ya estaban ahí
mirando la televisión en vivo
y entramos y era un silencio solemne
nadie decía nada solo atento a la
televisión y luego posterior cuando
presenciamos todos en vivo de colarse la
segunda torre pues ahí hubo un poco de
pánico poco de caos oficiales que
querían que querían responder que tiene
hacer algo entonces el supervisor nos
dice mira ya lo que estaban aquí ya se
fueron hay otras cosas que son
importantes porque se esperaba en los
trenes que existe día de hoy que
posiblemente adjudicado y van a haber
atentados los trenes entonces nuestro
rol en ese momento fue
desplazarnos a cerrar todas las
estaciones a evacuar la persona que
muchos estaban en estas estaciones
a todos del norte de manhattan la línea
1 2 y 3 el abs y de it es algo curioso
es que aún así encontraba una persona en
la plataforma esperando ese tren que
nunca llegaría y eso me impactaba o sea
no sé la gente bueno y eso hace 20 años
sobre la gente está muy informada nos
llamaba la atención que venían a abordar
el tren y le decía no oye no sabe lo que
está pasando y muchos no sabían lo que
estaba sucediendo
entonces ese fue nuestro rol hasta tarde
en la noche cuando estoy a terminar de
realizar esa labor de cierre de
estaciones de metro viene aquí a la
'zona cero' hacer qué exactamente bueno
entonces ya al día siguiente ya una vez
no había todo estaba paralizado una
ciudad ya al día siguiente pues había un
plan de contingencia de parte del
comando de distrito en los trenes y si
me tocó estar precisamente en el área en
la entrada donde estaban ese personal
multidisciplinario y buscando los
escombros buscando cuerpo parte del
cuerpo
lo que quedaba entonces sí recuerdo
vívidamente era algo surreal porque
el aire estaba lleno de ceniza parecía
nieve y todo el mundo entonces es algo
que el olor a muerte que es algo que no
lo puedo describir en palabras eso es
algo entonces ahí pues duramos algunos
dos o tres meses en mi caso personal
pero ese es recuerdos y lo tengo yo ni a
pesar de lo que había escuchado usted
ese día al día siguiente viene aquí sin
miedo
y creo que es algo natural ese instinto
es tu rol por ejemplo uno lo que quieres
ayudar es como un número uno es como una
máquina o sea para eso estamos
obviamente muchos oficiales pues todos
reaccionamos diferentes formas habían
oficiales que estaban muy nerviosos
les afectaba entonces esos oficiales
pues los supervisores tenían que estar
atentos a esas emociones a esos cambios
en los oficiales para esa parte de lo
que es un primer respondedor no solo la
policía y magnetto a los bomberos los
bomberos que entraron al edificio y
salir en ese día cuál es la imagen que
usted se encuentra cuando llega a la
zona pero te digo es algo surreal porque
total silencio nadie hablaba vehículo
todo un personal de seguridad pero lo
curioso es que nadie hablaba todo el
mundo estaba en su zona
fijado pensando pensamiento y es
entonces el aire y ese olor que no podía
escaparse de su incluso cuando llega a
la casa persistió por mucho tiempo no sé
éste salía de eso de tu cuerpo cuando su
familia se entera de que usted va a
venir a ayudar a las labores de rescate
aquí justo al día siguiente supongo que
no debe ser nada fácil para ellos asumir
es mira te cuento que en mi caso es un
descuido acuérdate que en los trenes los
celulares en ese entonces aún ahora no
trabaja y yo en un descuido no me
percaté de llamar a mi familiares porque
estábamos evacuando las personas los
trenes y no tuve la presencia en ese
momento de notificar a mis familiares no
fue cuando llegué en la noche que el
mensaje me llama mi mamá la familia dos
hermanos dónde está estamos preocupados
o sea eso es algo que estoy yo digo por
porque no pensé en llamarles y estamos
súper preocupado como que serían las
zonas más largas que no habían pasado
nunca imagínate una madre estaba
no podía creer porque piensa en lo peor
viendo la noticia y todo eso o sea que
un día como te digo inolvidable
inolvidable hablando de los que estaban
buscando mira me cuentan sí que lo que
estaban llenas los escombros me cuentan
como los cuerpos que caían se
estrellaban con el pavimento me
describieron que parecía que fueran
bombas o sea cuando caía entonces no lo
viví en presencia pero si me contaron lo
que salían de los escombros
ahora diciendo eso me atrae
magma lleva me lleva